The Joe Rogan Experience what are your
thoughts on that fight this weekend
because that's a big fight
uh my thoughts on it bro like is way
different from everybody else's you know
I mean because people call me crazy all
the time but I think it's gonna be like
the same fight that we see in your will
and Izzy
where you got two people just staring
each other down you know not trying to
make that move because you so you know
they both had the capabilities of
knocking each other out or Francis
Nagano versus the Derrick Lewis you know
I mean uh so and with everything the
hype being behind this fight too you
know uh Izzy is gonna hopefully like I
said if you don't apply his emotions
into it like he hasn't done with every
other fight
I feel like he's going to do enough to
win but I feel like Alex Ferrer is not
going to be able to apply that pressure
uh on uh Izzy just because he won't have
the energy to sustain that for five
rounds remember this is a five round
right because this is the fact that he's
cutting so much weight thank you you
know I mean and then plus we don't see
uh Alex Pereira move a lot anyway right
in his fights right you only seen with
Bruno Silva where he pushed him up
against the cage a lot and that was a
good fight to watch very good fight to
watch he's got hit in that fight I got
touched up real good bro Silva's a very
good strike yeah big facts you know I
don't know say good but I get what
you're saying he's in your weight class
yeah I know yeah yeah I'll be seeing
guys and I'll be like this is why they
winning these fights you know what I
mean so I know that you're not a boxer I
know that you're not a kickbox not a
heavy Striker because he's more of a jiu
jitsu more of a Grappler but Bruno said
we got good power right you know what
I'm saying so he's able to Wing some of
the punches because a lot of times like
Bruno silver began his ass even Jordan
Wright was touching them Jordan Wright
was touching uh Bruno Silva but then you
know Jordan Wright just got stood in
front of him got caught and it was all
and it don't take that much in the four
ounce gloves and that's why this rare
fight is so interesting though because
bahara has that you just need that one
shower he just need that one shot but
the thing about uh is he he is patient
and he would uh well we're not gonna
call it born but he would strategically
break you down all night long for 25
minutes but the problem if you gotta if
you gotta touch that leg all day you
don't touch it yeah you know if you
ain't gonna do nothing about it if
you're not gonna answer back that's what
he gonna do but I feel like in my heart
you know I mean that Alex Pereira
unfortunate he doesn't have the actual
ability to fight Izzy the way he needs
to win
for five rounds for five because he's so
big yeah that's one of the reasons but I
just think between both of them it's
gonna be a boring fight it's not going
to be as exciting as people think it
might be and that's the thing is he
needs that type of exciting fight right
now you know because uh the Jared
canonier fight you know we can say Paul
Acosta but that was so hot how long the
2020
um you know what I'm saying so we we've
been expecting this from the champ
because he's so popularized outside the
cage with you know the french tips the
pearl necklace you know I mean doing all
these little videos and and dancing and
all that just show me stuff but we want
to see that showcase in the cage as well
you know and that's my biggest thing
I'm impressed by Izzy and I'm a fan of
Izzy first though but I feel like if you
don't bring a fight to him he's not
gonna bring it to you that makes sense
yes so what you're saying so like he's
like doing the dance yeah yeah yeah big
fat I mean people forget that there was
quite a few fights where Anderson Silva
did the same thing he laid Talus latex
remember that fight yes yes you know
there was many fights where you know he
laid back and waited for guys to come
out with uh the Damian Mike yeah you
know what I'm saying and I mean boy
Danny was mad about that you know but at
the same time that's that's what he won
yeah you know because why would I why
would I engage with you knowing what you
trying to do right you understand yeah
so like I said with that being said I'm
not mad at Izzy because he gonna do
whatever it takes to keep that belt
that's the money right you know Alex
Perry wants that but the thing is though
I don't think
his ability is going to beat her in
order to take it away from you know and
they just gonna be standing right in
front of him and it's going to be a
kickboxing about and they were like oh
well the other ones with kickboxing but
you already seen from Izzy well I was a
little bit more emotional in those other
fights and that's why I lost
but then you see the Strategic Izzy now
I don't I don't see uh Alex bird being
interesting very interesting
um yeah I take into account what you're
saying about the five rounds and the
weight cut because that is a big factor
that's a big that's a huge Factor yeah
because Alex is so big but without the
wrestling threat because Izzy's not
really a guy who takes anybody down I'm
about to say yeah who out there
wrestling right so everybody think like
oh is he gonna turn to a wrestling no he
ain't no you you only fight the way you
train yeah you know and not saying you
don't work on that element of wrestling
but I don't see Izzy like shooter jab
shooting across shooting hook and double
it no that's not gonna happen I mean if
it does I'll be stunned I'll be shot I'm
sure it can't be shocked but then again
so now you got to engage with and that
boy a sniper out for real can we pull up
that uh if you don't mind please
uh sniping with the arrows yeah when he
shot the soccer ball bro man that that
that's crazy because my biggest thing is
though like
Alex Perez the same type of Beast too
right he's the Trap he waits all day and
once you expose yourself or you come
close enough
he hits you like Sean Strickland exactly
oh yeah Shawn right in front of him oh
but it wasn't even just standing right
in front of he was marching him down
with his hands down well yeah he keeps
his hands like here's a very strange
style yeah so here's him I ain't gonna
lie this was cold it's pretty bad this
was cold that's pretty badass and it
ain't one of those special little arrows
either like bow and arrows like this one
he's a maid in the house well he grabbed
the stick and grab a string yeah that's
a recurve bow that's a hard much harder
bow to shoot than what I shoot I shoot a
compound bow man that's that's his real
skill yeah look at him that that Roar
that he has is terrifying
I'm very excited about this fight man I
don't know you know what kind of
preparation he's done in terms of
getting himself lighter for a five round
fight and making sure that the cut is
not as bad I don't know but he looks
shredded shredded man and he looked like
he killing himself to make that weight
that's all I'm gonna say he certainly is
losing a lot of weight to make that way
he killed himself to get to that weight
um but like I said he's done it many
many times but you see Izzy doing all
his press doing all this stuff now be
honest with you I'd be like it's a
positive thing but at the same time like
I ain't never seen him do this much work
before or preparation for a fight when
it comes to like I mean yeah press yeah
yeah but they make you do that I mean
it's just mass and square guard but this
is the most I've ever seen I pay
attention to these Fighters all the time
because you know they're in the weight
class right I want to be these guys
right I want to take their belt right so
I pay close attention to what they do
all the time and especially Izzy because
he's a champ you know uh so besides it
just being uh ESPN plus you know he got
his own YouTube channel and everything
like that and I mean like I feel like he
didn't it up even more and there's
nothing wrong with that that's either
showing me that you have a lot of
confidence you know about yourself and
you were able to uh take this fight and
want to say not so serious but not a
serious because you got you doing other
stuff on top of this right Alex Perez
only focusing on training and fighting
right now there ain't no press for him
for real for real you know I mean so
he's taking it into initiative I'm
talking about Izzy to promote this fight
as best as he can so you also taken away
from your training at the end of the day
right so that's but I feel like he
thinks he's good enough to do what he's
going to do
in order to take a uh take time away
from his training but isn't that just
with the UFC obligates him to do because
pay-per-view points not with everything
but he has pay-per-view points I feel
you but I feel like he also is the only
one that speaks English Alex doesn't
speak true story so that makes it
difficult yeah but I feel like a lot of
stuff he's been doing on his own as well
um doing some extra stuff you know which
I don't mind it because you got to
promote the fight you got to do whatever
you got to do in order to get people to
buy in you know and be honest with you
it's not that hard of a buy-in because
even without being able to speak English
he's the only person that beat him only
person that knocked him out right you
know what I'm saying so that's that's an
easy sale on itself so my thing is why
I'm saying trying so hard
you know me like this is the one that if
I wasn't an MMA hit and I was just like
whatever just watching this stuff I'm
like oh okay that'd be interesting to
watch dude that already knocked them out
this dude is undefeated MMA but still
could be a close fight I'll watch it you
know but Izzy is is going about his uh
weight and like I said I don't know
what's going on in his head but I feel
like he's not trying to think about the
fight itself even though it is the press
conference and all this other stuff he's
trying to get himself more calm right he
want to be around more people I forget
who it's another fighter that talked
about that and the reason why he always
stayed
um you know in the present in interviews
because it it took him away from the
fight
um you know they always want to be in
the light I forget what I know what
you're saying so you know the more you
do other stuff you could just have fun
exactly and you ain't got to actually
focus on the the uh the actual Mission
itself you know you just go to the
mission you know so I don't know it's
it's two ways to go about it you know
and I feel like if Izzy goes out like I
said emotional he will get caught you
know so I feel like he needs to keep
doing like even when he play around like
oh I might just kick his leg and just
jab him the whole fight do that even
with him joking do that yeah you know
because at the same time that's how
you've been winning your fights whole
time a lot of a lot of